spend time getting clear
on the vision expand on that what are
some tips when we have multi-passions we
feel like we're everywhere we're chasing
shiny objects we're comparing ourselves
to others what are your tips for getting
clear number one on the vision so so the
challenge with social media today is
there's so many different people right
there's so many different influencers
and
some have a different style who do you
relate to like who is you when you watch
everybody who is you and what is your
area of expertise for us we sat there
and i said this is how i talk this is
how i tell my stories this is my style
of communication this is what i know a
lot about and then this is us we're
sticking to here versus well but i also
want to talk about this and i also want
to talk about this the more you stay
like this at the beginning the more you
can go like this later on because so
many times content creators want to go
wide very early that's a mistake stay
here at the beginning then as you get
bigger and bigger then you have the
opportunity to go this way
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres i'm the host of
your show here and we are here to help
you grow your influence with video and
then take that influence and grow a high
impact and a high profit online business
now if you're new to this podcast every
single tuesday we deliver a brand new
episode to you so make sure you're
subscribed wherever you like to consume
this content i am so excited because
today we're going behind the scenes of
another session from our grow with video
live conference we have someone that is
a huge online mentor to me i wish he was
an in-person mentor but he's definitely
an online mentor through his amazing
work that he does with valuetainment
this is none other than patrickbet david
if you're new to patrickbetdavid and the
work that he's doing right now to help
entrepreneurs let me just give you a
little insight about who you'll be
learning from today patrickbetdavid is
popularly known as the founder and ceo
of php agency a national financial
services marketing company with over 15
000 agents across the country and he is
the creator of valuetainment one of the
largest youtube channels for
entrepreneurs
his influence has amassed over
421 million views on his youtube channel
where he helps entrepreneurs with weekly
how-to tips motivation and interviews
with unique individuals patrick is the
best-selling author of the book your
next five moves teaching smart
entrepreneurs practical and effective
strategies for thinking more clearly and
achieving your most audacious
professional goals now in this episode
sean and pat are sitting down to discuss
the author notes of the book your next
five moves and they're going to be
sharing with you the content execution
strategy for how you could be scaling up
your content this year i'm excited for
you to jump into today's featured
content so lean in and let's get into
the conversation between patrick that
david and sean cannell
[Music]
15 moves to transform a weekly segment
into a channel focused on
entrepreneurship now your channel could
be focused on whatever you want he
talked about the seven categories and
there's so many but apply this to your
channel so pat let's dive into this and
can i get your author notes on these
sure
all right so
spend number one spend time getting
clear
on the vision expand on that what are
some tips when we have multi-passions we
feel like we're everywhere we're chasing
shiny objects we're comparing ourselves
to others what are your tips for getting
clear number one on the vision so so the
challenge with social media today is
there's so many different people right
there's so many different influencers
and some have a different style like you
know i had a guy there they asked me a
question they said hey should i drop
f-bombs because i see some people who do
and it's working out well for them i
said what do you mean drop f-bombs
because maybe that's why i'm not getting
any subscribership i said that's not why
you're not getting subscribership okay
you don't need to start cursing people
are not coming for that is
who do you relate to like who is you
when you watch everybody who is you and
what is your area of expertise for us we
sat there and i said this is how i talk
this is how i tell my stories this is my
style of communication this is what i
know a lot about this is where we want
to go to next here's where i see the
markets lacking and then this is us
we're sticking to here versus well but i
also want to talk about this and i also
want to talk about this the more you
stay like this at the beginning the more
you can go like this later on
the the challenge isn't that you will
never be able to go wide because so many
times content creators want to go wide
very early that's a mistake stay here at
the beginning then as you get bigger and
bigger then you have the opportunity to
go this way the same way with creating
wealth a lot of times people read books
and multiple streams of income you know
that's how you make your money today
maybe but to me i would much rather put
10 years in one industry like this then
make a few hundred million or 10 million
or 5 million dollars and then i'll go
like this but not i do this and i do
this and i do this and i do this and i
do this now pick one thing stick to that
and then you'll have the biggest
advantage later on
number two is consult with our creative
team to brainstorm new names for the
channel so if we're launching a new
project
and i want to hit this from a couple
levels you're far along in your career
you had dollars as you started
valuetainment but let's hit level number
one what's your advice
for somebody on that tip that is
thinking i don't necessarily have a
creative team i'm trying to sit down and
maybe start building a team
resources are maybe limited we have so
many entrepreneurs though in the room
and they're maybe trying to get the
mindset of investing how to build a
media company how do i hire let's speak
to level one and then maybe those that
are further along so so look i'm coming
out a guy at the airport we're talking
to a syrian guy he's trying he's an
actor trying to make it in hollywood but
he's also in miami so we're talking i
said you know if i was if i wanted to be
an actor here's what i would do
notice how adam sandler makes movies
with the same five guys over and over
and over again okay notice how vince
vaughn and owen wilson how many times
they did the same thing notice how
bradley cooper and jennifer lawrence
keep notice how people that started
making movies john favreau and vince
vaughn how you guys seen swingers if you
have ever seen that documentary before
it's a true story by the way okay you
watch all these movies right and you're
like okay wedding crashers they keep
doing things together this is the point
if you're at the beginning and you don't
have a lot of resources
pick three to five people that also want
to create content and then collaborate
with the technology you buy together
i'll put 500 you put 500 let's buy a few
things together and then let's use it
and then you'll find people i'll be your
camera guy you be my camera guy hey i'm
learning how to edit can you learn how
to edit there's so many nowadays
everything is accessible for people
learn how to edit i got a 10 year old
son that's learning how to edit okay i
mean it's so easy today to learn but i
would probably find another group like
here this is a great place to network
and meet other people when this event
ends don't go to your room or just go by
people that you know go shake hands with
people that you were impressed with the
most go network here and say hey here's
what we're thinking about doing what's
working out for you right and then start
a community and build on that today's
iphone
is what a great camera was ten years ago
a three thousand dollar camera five
thousand dollar cameras today's iphone
you can create picture-perfect content
with just the phone today and almost
everybody here's got an iphone
what about level two you're wanting to
scale up and you're scaling
valuetainment i just saw a picture of of
your building you're putting the logo on
the outside it's new levels for those
that are maybe like okay you're adding
personalities you're looking for talent
to make your content even better what
are just some brief tips on uh what you
think about scaling to the next level of
a media company
so the the media company it's it's
something that it's got to matter to you
because
it's it's a it's a very hard game it's
not easy to be able to go do that but if
you do want to go that route for us
we're recruiting talent right now and
the talent kind of has to fit
what our main core values are the number
one core value for us is capitalism i'm
concerned about america today i'm
concerned certain arguments about
certain economical systems is convincing
people today and i see a lot of people
this is a challenge a lot of times with
doers a lot of times doers
are quiet
complainers are loud
doers are quiet
doers just kind of put their heads down
and go build their family take care of
their wife their husband their kids
their good citizens locally and they
have a lot of tolerance so when people
are talking and they're loud they don't
say anything what they don't realize is
happening
is the people that are in the middle
that are oblivious think the complainers
are right and you're wrong for staying
quiet
so my fear is the fact that this great
system of capitalism that allows a
regular guy like me to win at the
highest level at the level that i'm at
right now and other people in america
around the world especially guy that
left iran
people think that's a bad system yeah
i'm gonna explain the story in a
completely different way okay i'm gonna
go out there make my nose and my own way
to make sure people still see that
capitalism the most fairest system
that's out there for people to build
their dream life whatever that may be
you may want to just make 100 grand
you're being at home you may want to
make a million dollars you may want to
be a billionaire it doesn't matter
capitalism allows for all those systems
to be in place capitalism allows
somebody to go with the company i'm
reading a book right now called after
steve meaning after steve jobs it just
came out a few weeks ago and it tells a
story about how many people that got
stock options at apple that's worth a
hundred times today ten years ago when
they were like guy was in there next
thing you know he's got 18 million
dollars in stocks some of you guys may
not start businesses but some of you
guys may team up with sean and the
company grows and you're part of that
grind together and you win that way
there's so many ways to do it but for us
once your messaging is clear
then the world starts realizing that you
really stand up genuinely for that
message then people show up and when
they do
realize that you sold the vision and the
dream
you have to come through on that vision
and the dream if you just say it and
it's lip service everybody will realize
it and then if you want to build that
media company it's 60 to 80 hours a week
for a long time so if you really want to
do that cannot wait to see you guys do
that part but the right person who wants
to build a media company and compete at
that level nobody needs to sell you or
push you away from doing it you're gonna
do it and you're gonna be okay with the
work that it requires
that's level two man tip number three or
s or move number three and i love this
one is buy and study every book on
marketing and media that exists
i can't believe you
i was like wow i mean how many but but i
want to uh to hear from you what what
would be some of the top first of all
the of course the principle is if you
ever want to kind of move into a new
vertical study the greats one of my
favorite tips from you is is there's a
certain number of reviews what's your
criteria for the books it used to be 200
right now it's probably 500. at least
500 reviews if a book's a fi if i want
to like i got two boys two girls if i
want to learn how to raise girls i'll
buy any book on a father raising a
daughter over 500 review reviews and i
want to read those books powerful okay
so what are a couple books on marketing
and media that you'd recommend uh this
room read it's it's the old one the
advertising man
movie yes it's the old one yeah anything
with kellogg there's another one called
the positioning
which is fascinating positioning is
fascinating contagious is a must it's an
orange book um there's so many of them i
did a whole video when i said the top
tend to read on marketing but you know
the the thing about marketing is people
think sales and marketing is the same
thing you know this you've been in
business long enough
there's a different ability in marketing
versus sales sales is here's the options
let me find out what your pressure
points are let me get the objections i
know the faqs we're getting to a point
which one do you want to go do you see
any reason we shouldn't get started
today no we do
marketing is storytelling knowing who
not to compete with you know who's going
to be a wasted time that you're going to
lose that battle like look at jake paul
jake paul fought
two ufc fighters
where did jake paul fight him did he
fight him in ufc rules or boxing rules
boxing why did he fight him in boxing
rules
what would have happened if jake paul
fought ben askren and ufc rules
who do you think it's game over wait so
so look how much of a genius he is he is
where he's getting people to fight in
his turf so marketing is you
getting your story to be in an area that
you have an advantage now your
competitors
number four is identify who we don't
want to be as much as who we want to be
what a powerful move
yeah very early on i mean i used to ask
myself do you want to get married do you
want to have kids what's the point of
getting married everybody i want to get
married why do you want to get married
that's what you're saying everybody's
getting married around me who cares if
everybody's getting married why do you
want to get married no one's ever asked
me that question before maybe you want
to ask that question
why do you want to get married half the
time when you date it's not about what
you're looking for it's what you know
for a fact you ain't looking for it you
know what i'm saying it's like listen
after the last two i know for a fact i'm
not going to be wanting this this and
this all the other stuff i can tolerate
the same thing goes with business right
who do you not want to be look at
everybody in the market and say i'm not
that guy
that's not me this isn't me not who you
want to be you already know who you want
to be it's who you don't want to be and
that part takes a little bit more work
to figure out
we're going to jump right back into
today's featured conversation but i
wanted to let you know about a brand new
free master class and downloadable guide
that's available for you at
21videotips.com if you like content like
this that you're learning from
patrickbetdavid and sean cannell you can
get 21 more video marketing tips from
people like patrickbetdavid vanessa lau
pat flynn alex hermosi and so many
industry experts that are using powerful
strategies for their video marketing
today
you're gonna learn the best kept
business secrets inside of this master
class and free downloadable guide so
head over to 21videotips.com
to get instant access for free and learn
how you can level up your business and
brand from today's top industry experts
now let's get back into today's featured
content
move number five make the channel about
the mission rather than my personality
and one of the powerful points in your
talk was you're building a business and
a personal brand but you're saying make
the channel about the mission explain
that
yeah so
you know because again if you're trying
to be an individual brand alone it's not
the mission it's got to be around you
and your personality that's going to be
fine but if it is around building a
company around the brand it's got to be
a mission
because the mission all of a sudden what
happens the following say for instance
how many guys have seen that one channel
it's called dad how do i have you seen
that channel that how do i have you guys
heard of that channel that how do i do
you guys know how many subscribers he
got in his first month
one million subscribers on his first
month okay
one million the guy's in his mid 50s
right so he says
hi i don't know what his name is we've
communicated a few times he says
today i'm going to show you what to do
if you have a leak in the plumbing this
is what you do it's a five minute video
and he shows you how to do it today i'm
gonna show you what happens if your door
not breaks down here's how to fix it you
go to home depot you buy this this this
he's just kind of like
what a sweet man i love this man
man i need to know because secretly i
have no clue how to fix my plumbing when
it leaks
other people need to watch this as well
cool
for that is the mission is more about i
wish i had a father like him growing up
that taught me how to do this right
people connect with that but to him
that's him it's not really i'm going to
take over the world i'm going to do this
i'm going to do that but if you're
trying to build it into a company the
mission is going to matter a lot because
people connect emotionally to mission
this book again i'm reading after steve
one of the guys that's around with apple
who had a different way of looking at
the company than tim cook he kept trying
to think about the way that steve jobs
built the company because to him it was
all about think different versus to tim
cook it's hey what a spotify charge this
much let's pay this much boom now we got
20 million reoccurring people that are
using our apple
so but steve jobs would say i don't care
what spotify charges we think different
you use apple because of this so apple
has lost
the mission and division it's become a
little bit more logical even though it's
a three trillion dollar company right
now two trillion dollar company right
now the younger generation is not saying
i want to go work for apple the younger
engineers coming out saying i want to
work for who what's the younger
generation say they want to work for the
younger engineers coming out of harvard
who do they want to work for one guy
elon musk because to him it's what we're
going to go to mars we're going to go to
this we're going to go build this we're
going to so it's like the mission
division man i want to i want to be
around this guy i want to work with a
guy like this that's when you're drawing
people in so yeah the mission and the
vision is going to matter if that's your
vision
number six create a new logo name and
website that embodies a leading educator
this is maybe something we don't take
that seriously we just throw up some
channel art we get on canva we do some
things this was a serious move for you
explain that a little bit yeah again if
it matters to you my son picks out his
clothes my middle son my second son
my oldest son he'd go out with sandals
he could care less what he wears i'm not
even kidding with you my middle son he
goes
he takes my cologne he does this he puts
the gel perfectly puts his necklace out
he puts the belt tucks his shirt in
perfect nice shoes and he walks out like
this okay to him
he's a brand to my oldest son he could
care less here's a point if your logo
excites you because there's a story
behind it that's what matters it excites
me because the logo we have with the
lion the valuetainment logo it's a lion
and an eagle
it's tattooed on mario's forearm here
it's a story about a fiction book i
wrote that we're publishing right now
it's taking me 11 years to finally feel
comfortable publishing this book because
it's a story about me being from iran
assyrian it's depth to me
you'll feel it because it matters to me
but if it's like listen i really don't
care about what kind of clothes i wear
don't worry about it neither do people
either you may sell people in a
different way so low going color only
matters
if you're that kind of a person if
you're not don't overthink it and
when maybe not a logo if you don't have
to overthink it if that's not a value
but what do you think about the value of
picking the right name especially as a
content creator in business or in any
niche as well as securing your website
as a to-do list in these moves it has to
matter to you again it goes back to you
okay folks on three scream out your
favorite name in the world that you gave
to your kid
or if you don't have a kid right now you
would name your kid that name because
you love it you ready on three one two
three
awesome okay for me
my favorite name in the world is first
patrick
gabriel with david patrick's me
gabriel's my dad that dave is my last
name my second name my wife and i love
this name dylan do you know why i love
dylan does anybody love the name dylan i
love dylan because i love luke perry the
guy was a stad luke terry right i like
this dylan guy right everybody had their
own character to me luke perry was like
the bomb right chill cool you know i
like the name dylan i like dylan my
daughter's name is senna rose bedavid
you know why senna because i love
ironton center the race car driver from
brazil it's spelled the same way as a
race car i've watched this documentary
over a hundred times i'll sit at
midnight and watch the documentary of
senna and get the chills all over
anytime i want to compete
anytime i'm in a place where i'm just
kind of like we're going to go take
we're going to do something big i put
the documentary at night because my
blood
is boiling so my daughter's name is
senna rose but david rose is my
grandma's name sent us the race car
driver's name everything has an has a
meaning to it but to me to you if your
company's name
has meaning to you it's going to have
meaning to everybody else because of the
way you sell it to them
make sense it's the best way i'll
explain company names number seven is
attend social media industry uh
conferences and learn different
strategies wow you're making the right
moves
and uh i just wanna ask on that one how
do you decide you're super busy you're
running two companies at a incredibly
high level putting in a ton of hours how
much time do you budget for learning
and conferences or continued education
regularly i don't have a choice here's
why this is this is my interpretation of
what you just said the only way like i
in my mind i'm convinced i'm not yet
ready for the next level whatever the
next level is for me right in my mind so
if i want to get to the next level i
have to meet a new pbd new version of
myself okay so
this year i look at the weaknesses of
our businesses and our management team
bless you on the insurance side on my
sales side and by attainment home office
side right by attending as a startup
insurance we have i hired five c-suite
executives they all have fancy degrees
they all work for big insurance
companies and now they're coming to work
for a guy like me and i hired them all
at the same time it's problematic when
you hire five c-suite alpha people who
are all very good at what they do who
have all been part of a publicly traded
company and you put them in now you got
seven of them and they're working with
me
so i looked at everybody and i started
seeing that people are having a hard
time having crucial conversations
together
and i said whose fault is this
i said okay no problem here's what i'm
gonna do there's an organization in utah
called crucial learning okay
i used them 15 years ago or 12 years ago
love their program
they're 15 000
to use by the way i don't make money if
you call these guys they're 15 dollars
to use and then you gotta fly everybody
in and you gotta get a hotel that's
around thirty thousand dollars
two weeks ago tuesday wednesday i
brought them in they trained twenty of
my employees of valuetainment for two
days straight i was in the room from
eight o'clock in the morning till four
o'clock in the afternoon the next day
thursday friday i flew them out to go to
addison texas first one was in fort
lauderdale the second one was in addison
texas they trained all my c-suite
executives and my directors
for eight to four two days an hour
because we needed to learn how to have
crucial conversations together then i'm
taking all my top 20 earners sales
leaders and i'm putting them in the room
then i'm going to have my 40 vps take
their 20 best sales people sit them in
the room to learn how to have tough
conversations together because 90
of the reasons why companies don't grow
and there's challenges in any
organization
people do not know how to talk to each
other in a tough way they don't know so
they do the biggest mistake which is
what
don't even talk to each other do you
know what happened ever since by the way
and every time i've done these types of
meetings which i do a lot the first
person everybody wants to have a crucial
conversation with is who
with me they're like well pat you know i
want to have this conversation i just
want you to i respect the work you do
you're a great leader however there's a
couple areas i'm like okay give it to me
right but i'm proud of them because
they're learning how to do this so to go
back and to answer your question for you
10 years ago when we were going to do
creating content i wasn't yet convinced
we went to a social media world i don't
know what it was it was in san diego and
one of the guys his name was michael
hyatt you may know michael hyde he's
from tennessee he used to run thomas
nelson i want to say was the ceo and he
got up and he gave a message
and about podcasts and i said you know
what i understand that and another guy
named john lee dumas spoke he was an
army guy and i'm an army guy i said if
these guys are doing it you know what
let me consider this so they played the
role in my life where maybe other people
play the role in your life so these
investments
as you make make these investments
everyone's going to have some kind of
shift in you but hopefully you get the
right messaging to leave but for me it's
ongoing that's probably never gonna stop
for the rest of my life
all right so we're gonna do number eight
and uh because of our time allotment uh
i need a couple of things number one
uh i need you to message pbd on social
media to see if he'll do a part two on
the podcast number three
uh number two um uh we're going to look
at this final tip here and uh these have
been so amazing though number two though
is get the book because you could see
because you're like wait you said
there's gonna be all 15 moves then you
need to listen that podcast that we
hopefully do together and then uh of
course uh number three though is
seriously get this book this guy's a pro
yeah it's got some problem
you just put the pressure pressure on me
i got it
i like your style no hype no hype at all
man this book is is really amazing your
next five moves and uh this is page uh
232 and you're not gonna know all the
tips but we will we will hit number
eight uh to land the plane on 15 moves
you were so strategic and just think it
through i'm gonna lay out my moves as
i'm gonna approach my next target and
that's how we're ending our day right so
i hope you're taking notes and thinking
about what are some of your next moves
for your business your brand uh but
number eight is start learning the
language of media and what needs to be
tracked of course in your session you
track you hit a lot of this but i'd love
your audit
author notes on learning the language of
media but also for you what matters when
it comes to
tracking in valuetainment
everything is data so for me
seven years ago uh 2014 will be what
eight years ago tom ellsworth who
uh is a guy that introduced me to
vistage and i was part of vista she was
the guy that my pastor said you gotta
meet this guy tom ellsworth smartest guy
in the church i meet tom and then one
guy whispers he says you know who that
guy said i have no clue who he is he
gave 660 000 to the church last year i
said you give 660 yeah 10 6.6 okay
respect how you doing good to meet you
you know it's like so then we start
talking i'm like this guy is brilliant
so he was part of a company called jam
that they sold it to ea sports for 680
million dollars so we're sitting there
we're talking to each other
and while we're having this conversation
he starts mentoring about media and all
this stuff 2014 he says pat you need a
bi
i said bi we need to hire business
analytics expert
like how much are they 60 grand nope i'm
good not right now we can't hire them
just trust me
you need to our business analyst i said
i'll we can get one
eight bucks an hour you know i mean you
understand what i'm saying it's like
listen just trust me it's 60 year
minimum we have a good one we'll get him
i said okay whatever we can hire one he
says but my recommendation we hire three
he says we hire three we keep two and
then one of them stays with us that's
the best one we give him a raise like so
you want me to do 180 it's not really
180 it's just i'm telling you i'm like
so i said okay whatever i'm not
convinced guys i'm very skeptical at
this time because in my mind i'm doing
15 grand a month and there's better
places i can invest 15 grand a month in
my eyes right he says just trust me you
hired me to be your president let me do
my job i said fine whatever so he goes
he hires a three
brings them in
three weeks into it
these guys come to my office
they say hey mr badavi we notice a
couple things we want to bring to your
attention did you know that when it
comes down to your ratios of licensing
to how many new agents you bring did you
know that this state does the best
ratios because of this person and that
person and did you know this state that
we think are the best in the company
they're actually the worst in getting
people licensed
i said let me see this thing right here
that's pretty sick is this serious that
this one tom this is big i told you
so the next thing you know i get on a
call and i start going and visiting
those offices licensing came up we
doubled licensing we went from 500 to
1200. i'm like
and he said hey mr may david we have
three other things we'd like to share
whenever you have some time we want to
show this to you and i would come in so
if you look at this here when it comes
down to this data you notice that
i'm like oh my god that's awesome so
then one day i get out of control i'm
like you know what i want you to pull up
what i want you to pull up which is kind
of weird stuff you're going to hear from
me i want you to pull up which zodiac
sign makes the most money in the company
so i'm thinking to see how good these
guys are whether they can pull it up no
problem give us one day
these guys are serious the next day do
you know and i'm thinking because i'm a
libra i'm like for sure it's going to be
libros at the top
so i say tell me who's at the top he
says well the best sign for people who
make the most money is aries
i said what
i said what's two
cancer what's three
you know who was last libra was last i
was so good i'm like this doesn't work
this is not accurate right i said throw
this trash away i don't want to look at
it again right but the point is
everything became data because i all of
a sudden it's like somebody put on a
lens and i see like a new dimension i
never saw before
data allows you to adjust and improve in
areas and not put time in areas that
you're not getting the return and put
more time into areas you are getting a
return same thing that i did with the
insurance company we did the same exact
way with vitamin and obviously the data
shows what happened with us because
without data you're not going to improve
so yes great point
on the data if you're not doing it
highly recommend it
well there's eight of your next moves
can we give it up for patrick bett david
well i hope you enjoyed that
conversation from growth video live with
patrick beth david and sean cannell and
let me know in the comments i know we
only got through a few of those steps do
you want to hear the rest of them we
would love to bring patrick back on or
have a discussion between myself and
sean but let me know in the comment
section on youtube do you want the rest
of the author notes from patrickbetdavid
let me know by leaving a review or that
comment in the youtube channel we'll
also make sure to link patrick's book
down below and you can get that on audio
or in kindle or physical copy it is an
excellent book that i recommend that you
read from cover to cover with your
highlighter and pens ready
thank you so much for being a part of
what we're doing here at think media we
have so many amazing conversations like
this coming to the podcast so make sure
you're subscribed wherever you like to
consume your content and i want to thank
those who have been rating and reviewing
the podcast you can go to apple podcast
to leave your review or leave a comment
down below on the youtube channel
today's featured community member comes
from risensuns89 advice and insight is
unmatched i've been listening to this
podcast for almost two years now and i
finally started my youtube channel a few
months ago trust me the advice and
insight they offer is truly unmatched
thank you think media well rising suns
thank you so much for leaving that
comment and i'm so excited that you
started your youtube channel i cannot
wait to see what happens in 52 weeks
from now when you've got one video out
every single week what that's gonna do
to your business and your brand
congratulations on getting started well
hey if you've not liked this video if
you're watching on youtube make sure you
hit that like button and have you shared
this podcast with a friend if you know
an entrepreneur a content creator who
needs to know information like this then
make sure you share this podcast with
them it would be an honor to get to help
your friends and family grow their
online business as well thanks so much
for being a part of what we're doing
here at think media and i'll catch you
in the next episode bye
[Music]